مرحبا صباح النور للجميع والفعل حاج
الغريبه في تونس هو احدى اكبر التظاهرات
صباح الانوار اكبر تظاهرات الدينيه
والسياحيه في المنطقه انطلق منذ الاسبوع
الفارت ومازال متواصل حيث ياتي كامل
اليهود التونسيين وحتى غير التونسيين من
كافه انحاء العالم لزياره اقدم معابد
افريقيا اقدم معبد يهودي افريقي يتواجد في
جزيره جربه التونسيه وهناك توقعات بزياده
بنسبه 40% في عدد الزائرين لهذه السنه وهو
يعتبر احدى ابرز مظاهر نجاح الموسم
السياحي التونسي وتتجهز له الدوله
والسلطات التونسيه وخاصه وزاره السياحه
بالعديد التظاهرات والانشطه الثقافيه
والترفيهيه وكذلك تقوم السلطات الامنيه
بتامين الجزيره وكامل زوار تونس كما ينبغي
على امتداد ايام وهو
رمز من اكبر رموز التعايش السلمي ما بين
مختلف الديانات في تونس ورساله حب وسلام
الى العالم لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات